[Applause]
all right
thank you
thank you everybody
thank you
so
thank you so much
it's pretty exciting time uh in my life
i just um found out just a few a little
while ago that my children's book johnny
the walrus is now the number one
best-selling children's book or actually
book period on amazon out of all books
um
thank you and
you know it's for those who aren't
familiar it's a board book for
preschoolers about a child who
identifies as a walrus
and i think i can now say that it's the
best-selling
walrus-related children's book of all
time i think
so i'm excited about that
and i'm even more excited because amazon
was very upset about this and they were
doing things to kind of stifle the book
and they took our ads down and they did
all these things and the amazon
employees were crying and we're talking
about how traumatized they are by it and
after that is when it's best-selling on
amazon so i just think that's fantastic
um i want to thank you all for being
here tonight i want to thank you
especially for having
the bravery and courage to expose
yourself to
my harmful dangerous traumatic opinions
i know it's not easy for you it's not
easy for either of us you know if it's
hurtful
for you to hear my opinions think about
how it is for me i have to say them so
it's even harder for me
in fact some some videos leaked
yesterday
showing a meeting that leftist activists
on this campus had with university
administrators recently
and the activists wanted to shut down
the speech
but they weren't able to do that so the
administrators instead were helping them
game plan a protest
because this is the kind of privilege
you have as a leftist on a college
campus university officials will meet
with you and console you
and help you
organize a protest against speakers you
don't like and they're out there right
now and in fact they um it was kind of
nice they're protesting right now and i
looked out the window i saw them and
they were having they got pizza for
themselves so my producer went out and
got me a slice of pizza
so i had a nice little snack
i appreciate that
um
and for the protesters you know feeding
a best-selling children's author is a is
an act of of charity i think
now
and you know some of these activists
were complaining one of them said that
this was the most exhausting time of his
life
uh which means that you've led a very
privileged life if if me coming to speak
is your most exhausting experience as a
father of four i have like 10
experiences a day that are
more exhausting than this speech and i'm
the one again giving the speech
now it may be funny to laugh at leftists
who panic over opposing ideas and it is
funny you know it's i mean hilarious
but there's a reason they react this way
the reason is that they're nursing
they're protecting guarding a world view
which cannot hold up against even the
slightest scrutiny
and at some level they realize this
which is why they desperately guard
themselves against exposure to contrary
viewpoints this is also why they're in
the midst of a nuclear meltdown over
elon musk
buying twitter
you know they're afraid that musk will
make
good on his promise to allow everyone to
basically speak freely and this will
make twitter unsafe they say
and what they mean is that it will be
psychologically unsafe because there
will be potential land mines all over
the place threatening to
explode their whole fragile flimsy
shoddily constructed duct tape together
world view
a slight breeze can knock the whole
jenga tower down and they know it and
that terrifies them
and nowhere
in no ideological arena is that more
true than in the arena of gender
now we know that left-wing gender
ideology
teaches of course that gender is fluid
and socially constructed
anybody who feels like a man whatever
that means
really is one and anyone who feels like
a woman whatever that means
really is that
this is false it bears no relation to
the truth
it doesn't make it within 100 miles of
the vicinity of the truth
and it can easily be exposed as a
falsehood an incoherent jumble of
nonsense and that can be done just by
asking a few basic questions
one of the most basic questions
to the person who says that men can be
women is and this is the question i've
been asking for a long time i even have
a film about it is uh
what is a woman like what do you mean
when you use that word what are you
trying to say they can't answer that
question or any other question yet this
ideology
has taken over the culture
it can't withstand scrutiny
it crumbles immediately under the most
mild interrogation and yet it has had
enormous cultural success
so what i'd like to do for the rest of
the talk tonight is examine why and how
it has achieved this success i think
there are three areas three sort of
strategies which have allowed them to
accomplish this
the first is language
okay the trans agenda has infiltrated
our society largely through language and
i don't mean that the gender ideologues
use language to make compelling
arguments
not at all
rather they manipulate
language itself they make it into their
pet
they talk about preferred pronouns but a
pronoun is a grammatical construct it
has to be deployed according to the laws
of grammar not the fickle whims of the
individual to whom it refers
if i'm if i'm standing on this stage
and you want to communicate to somebody
else about the fact that i am standing
on this stage
you will say
he is standing on that stage
it would be grammatically and factually
incorr
incorrect excuse me to say she is
standing on that stage
as she denotes a human female which i am
not
it would be incorrect to say they are
standing on the stage as that indicates
more than one person on the stage which
there is not
it would be incorrect to say
ze or zur is standing on the stage
because that would seem to suggest that
there's some sort of space alien on the
stage which
as far as you know i am not in a similar
way if i'm standing on a stage
and i insist that my preferred
preposition
is off
it would make no sense for you to
respect my preferences and tell
everybody that i'm standing off the
stage now i may prefer the word off i
may think that i am off the stage i may
identify as somebody who's standing off
the stage but that doesn't change the
objective fact that i am indeed on the
stage prepositions nouns and pronouns
and verbs i mean unless they're used in
a
fictional story or poem or something
are usually meant to convey objective
facts about reality
if they're not going to perform that
function then they no longer perform any
function at all and meaningful useful
words
have been reduced to impotent nonsense
but shouldn't we just be polite and call
people by their preferred pronouns
anyway because it's the nice thing to do
we'll answer no and here's why
first you don't generally call somebody
a pronoun when you're speaking to them
if you want to address a person directly
you just use his or her name
and a name can be whatever you want it
to be i mean if a woman says her name is
fred or a man says his name is sally
i'll call her fred and him sally because
names are by definition personal
basically arbitrary
pronouns are objective and also
generally more distant you're usually
called by a pronoun when you're not
physically present for the discussion
so when somebody insists on a preferred
pronoun
he's trying to prevent you
from using proper grammar
even when he's not in the room with you
he's saying
whenever you refer to me even if i'm ten
thousand miles away you must abandon the
rules of grammar and parrot whatever
gibberish i assign to you that's not
only absurd it's arrogant in the extreme
he's trying to control what you say
about him when he's not even in the room
that's not how language work that works
that's not how grammar works
that's not how life works
it's not my job to enforce your
self-perception
so you might see yourself as a woman but
that's not how i see you
and that's not what you actually are and
so i can't be required to affirm what i
don't believe and what i know to be
untrue and further it's not my job to
adopt
your perception of yourself
how crazy is it that this is what people
think and that we that so many people
just accept it
you know
as i explained on dr phil
i might
perceive myself as handsome and
brilliant please don't laugh at that but
i said please don't laugh
but i can't require that everybody who
speaks about me also have that same
perception
i can't say to you well i see myself
this way and so you have to see me that
way again that's just simply not how it
works
my self-perception is not a project
that the whole world has to take on
that's why we call it self-perception
second point using an incorrect pronoun
incorrect as in a pronoun that doesn't
properly convey objective reality
is not only nonsensical but it's also
dishonest
so if i say
she drove to the store when i'm really
talking about a man driving to the store
i'm lying
now i may be lying with the best
intentions but a lie is a lie i am
conveying an untruth
it's bad to convey on truths because the
person i'm speaking to whoever it is
deserves to know the truth
and if i don't think they deserve to
know the truth and i shouldn't be saying
anything to them at all
and also the person i'm referring to
deserves the truth which is why if i'm
talking directly to that person i'm also
going to use the correct pronoun
a confused and deluded person needs the
truth he doesn't need us to participate
in and encourage his delusion
that might be what he thinks he wants
but it's not what he needs it's not
going to help him in the long run
but doesn't grammar and language evolve
over time that's the other thing you
always hear
well it does however language evolves
according to coherent rules and
standards
that's not what we're talking about here
we're talking about people making up
their own rules individually
which isn't evolution that's just the
collapse of language
in order for language to work there have
to be shared rules that we all
understand and agree to and that makes
sense
if you don't have that then there's no
way to communicate
um
language is a symbol you know it's a
sound that's meant to represent
something
so we say elephant to talk about
elephants camels to talk about camels
things could have worked out so that we
say camels to talk about the animals
that we now think of as elephants and
vice versa
there's no reason why we had to use
those particular sounds to represent
those animals that's just how it worked
out
it's why language can shift and change
over time
but
changes in language happen organically
at least that's what's supposed to
happen
due to a wide combination of influential
influences people begin to slightly
adjust the verbal symbols they use for
certain things
and eventually the official grammatical
rules as written in grammar textbooks
will change also but they change
descriptively not proscriptively they're
describing and codifying a change that's
already underway
what's happening with pronouns is not
like this at all
this is a top-down
change the grammar rules are being
changed proscriptively our cultural
elites have decided for ideological
reasons that we ought to be using
different words and they are berating
and scolding and punishing us until we
comply that is not evolution of language
this is an intentional manipulation of
language which is a very different thing
just look at what they're doing with the
made-up nonsensical word latinx or le
tinx however you pronounce it
nobody in the hispanic community uses
that word or likes it and yet the
cultural elites keep using it and
pushing it and pushing it hoping that
eventually people will submit and just
start adopting it in daily use
if and when that day happens
they'll then turn around and say well
look at that language evolved
but calling that natural evolution it's
like injecting drugs into a lab rat and
calling it natural evolution when it
grows a third ear that's not natural
now the other strategy very much related
and connected to the first is to sow
confusion
this is the other way that gender
ideology takes hold of our society
it's to make the issue of sex and gender
seem complicated complex the sort of
thing that you have to rely on the
experts to explain to you
and conveniently the experts are all
leftists and most of them are paid off
by the pharmaceutical companies who are
making billions of dollars off of the
gender confusion epidemic
the refusal to define the word woman is
is part of this
now they say that nobody can define it
it's an abstract philosophical concept
it doesn't mean anything really they say
and although it doesn't mean anything
they still want you to take a man
seriously
when he says he identifies as a woman
despite the fact that he's identifying
as something that according to them
means nothing
but none of this makes sense or is true
the word woman just like the word man
has a definition
a woman by definition is an adult human
female a man is an adult human male
those are the only two options available
for the human species
that's it
there is no third sex
doesn't exist
all humans who have ever lived have been
either male or female
what do we call this we call this a
binary system
it's the only system available to us
it's the reason why if you go on amazon
and you order a shirt with the
non-binary pride flag
it will come in either men's or women's
sizes
because there's
no other third option
now
what is a female well a female is
somebody with x x chromosomes a female
reproductive system female gametes or
eggs
and the ability in principle to ovulate
and bear offspring now there are females
who suffer from illnesses mutations
injuries deformities
or who simply are postmenopausal which
prevent them from performing some of
these natural female functions that does
not make them any less female and it
also does nothing at all to invalidate
the binary
it is instead what we call an exception
that proves the rule here's why
when a female cannot bear children
we know that something is wrong
physically
and we know this
because females are supposed to be able
to bear children
when a man cannot bear children we know
that it is not a sign of anything having
gone wrong because men are not supposed
to be able to bear children and never
ever have
so if as a woman you go to the doctor
and tell them
that you're unable to conceive children
in your womb
he's not going to say to you oh well
maybe that means that you're a
non-binary maybe that's just who you
that's just who you are that's just how
it is
you're probably pretty upset if he said
that
no he's going to run some tests and he's
going to figure out what's wrong in your
body maybe it can be fixed maybe it
can't but
it's just a fact that something is wrong
and he can almost certainly find out
what it is
if as a man you go to the doctor and
tell him that you're unable to conceive
children in your womb
he'll run some tests to see what's wrong
with your mind
or at least that's how he would have
responded up until recently now because
society has lost its mind
he might give the man hormone pills to
help him transition into a woman but
you'll note that
even after transition still the man will
not be able to ovulate or conceive
children or perform any other
exclusively female function because he's
not a female and will never be one
he's a man that means he's a male with
xx chromosomes or male anatomy male
gametes
but uh or rather xy chromosomes sorry
there we go
but there's a there's a lot more to
being a male than just that
indeed
the physical differences between men and
women are not confined to the
reproductive system they can be found in
every bodily system in every part of the
body
a man is male down to his bones down to
his cells down to his dna
even after he dies his bones will attest
to the biological reality they can dig
him up a hundred years from now and find
his bones and find out that he was male
the bones will not declare his pronouns
or affirm his self-perception
there will be no self the self is gone
but the man remains
now many of these biological differences
by the way happen to give him a distinct
advantage over women in sports
differences like that account for the
fact that women have 20 percent less
muscle mass on average than men 40 less
upper body strength 33 less lower body
strength
smaller fast twitch muscle fibers
smaller lungs smaller hearts shorter
legs
more estrogen less testosterone a lower
capacity to produce oxygen when they
exert themselves
these advantages are why the fastest man
in the world
is always faster than the fastest woman
and if the fastest man dies
the next fastest
will be faster than the fastest woman in
fact if the 100 fastest men all got on a
plane to go to a fastest man retreat
and the plane crashed and they all died
the 101st fastest man who's now fastest
by inheritance will still be faster than
the fastest woman
and then the next 100 could get on a
plane and they can all die too
because they didn't learn their lesson
from the from the first batch
and whatever man remains he's now faster
than the fastest woman
there has never been a time
in the olympics attest to this there's
never been a time not ever not once
when the women's racing or swimming
champions were faster on average than
the men in the olympics it has never
happened
ever in history
and never will
these advantages are why there's a whole
website dedicated to comparing high
school boys track and field champions
against female olympians
the high school boys outperformed the
female olympians in almost every
category by huge margins
so take one example
the new balance nationals outdoor meet
is one of the preeminent high school
track meets in the country the two in
the 2016
if the 2016 high school boys finalists
in the 100 meters
were to have raced against the 2016
female olympic finalists
the fastest woman would have come in
ninth place against high school boys
gold silver bronze in places four
through eight would all be held by high
school boys against female olympians
this holds true in almost every event
and it's not just track and it's not
just hypothetical back in 2017 a soccer
team
uh the u.s women's national soccer team
scrimmaged against 15 year old boys
and lost five to two
male and female athletes are so
different separated by such a vast
biological chasm
that you can actually count the total
number of dunks made by wnba players in
the history of the league
total and that number is 28.
23 of them were by the same player
for by contrast there's a player in the
nba who dunked the ball 300 times by
himself in one season
so that's one player in one year dunking
it almost 10 times more than the entire
wnba over the course of a quarter
century men and women are different a
lot different
men are stronger they're faster they're
better at almost every competitive sport
literally every line of evidence
supports this
all of the evidence all of it supports
the claim that men in general have
biological advantages over women in
sports there is no evidence going the
other way
which is why the gender ideologues on
that side do not produce evidence
they have none to produce they cannot
defend their position
and because they can't defend their
position that motivates them even more
to employ the third and final strategy
and the one with the greatest
consequence for our civilization
that is to indoctrinate very young
children
and as far as they're concerned the
younger the better they're succeeding
a gallup survey recently showed that the
number of trans-identifying people in
gen z
is 10 times higher than older
generations
20 percent of gen z identifies as lgbt
that's double millennials
and millennial
identification is double the boomers
and boomers are double their parents
generation
so the lgbt camp has doubled in size
with every successive generation since
1940
that's not an accident
and it doesn't even include my own kids
generation where the numbers will know
about doubt be far more dramatic
my kids generation are really the first
to have these ideas forced on them
practically since birth
and that's how we so commonly hear now
about three and four-year-old kids who
identify quote-unquote as the opposite
gender
now the idea that a child can choose his
gender is indefensible
and would still be indefensible even if
the broader claims of left-wing gender
theory were true which they aren't
as the parent like i said of four kids
um one of them currently five years old
i can tell you that a four or
five-year-old child can't reliably make
any choice
in any context
period
um take a four-year-old child to baskin
robbins and ask him to pick which flavor
he prefers
and he'll give you 14 different answers
before collapsing into tears
he cannot make that decision
their parents are at restaurants the
waiter comes up and they'll sit there
and they'll ask their four-year-old well
what would you like to eat from the kids
menu pic here's five options and the
waiter's gonna stand there for 45
minutes while the kid debates it
i've been through this with my own kid
recently i was at a restaurant i made
this mistake i don't know why i made it
was a rookie mistake
and i asked my uh my son
what would you like to eat
and he told me that he wants to eat
salmon
and i said you don't want to eat salmon
you've never you don't even know what
that is what are you talking about you
know
like i know better than you do what you
want to eat
why did i even ask
that's the way it goes with kids a child
that age has not developed a cognitive
ability to assess a variety of options
and decide which course is correct
healthy safe
sensible
he will not have that ability for many
years he certainly won't have it when
he's 12
which is the age when so many kids now
are choosing quote unquote to be
chemically castrated and sterilized
forever foreclosing the opportunity to
have children in the future
they are quote deciding to give up on
reproducing and to give up on so much
else at an age where in any other
context we would all agree
they're not equipped to make practically
any choice at all
the prefrontal cortex in the brain which
controls our long-term planning and
discernment isn't fully online until the
age of 25.
we have kids half that age
younger than half that age who are
making life altering lifelong decisions
decisions that their adult versions of
themselves will have to live with
forever
until tragically so many of them kill
themselves because that's that's the
path that we're putting these kids on
now of course nobody can choose his or
her own sex that matter is irrevocably
settled by our chromosomes and
reproductive organs but the leftist
position here is so preposterous that
even if one grants the premise that
gender can theoretically be chosen the
left would still be wrong in thinking
that four-year-olds or twelve-year-olds
can choose it
there's a reason why young children are
not entrusted with any legal powers or
responsibilities they can't vote drive
take out a mortgage buy a gun buy a
ticket for an rated movie by alcohol buy
cigarettes buy practically anything
because they're simply too young to do
so
you know a four-year-old can't go get a
tattoo
in any state that i've heard of
very young children can't even grasp the
distinction between fantasy and reality
so if you tell a toddler that batman
isn't real
he'll just stare at you blankly because
the phrase isn't real
is empty in his mind he doesn't know
what you mean by that
are we supposed to believe that people
this ignorant and immature so innocently
detached from reality can make
meaningful declarations and decisions
about their gender identity
a boy who says he's a girl doesn't even
know what a girl is he doesn't know
anything
there was a viral twitter thread last
year that made this point very well
though unintentionally i think
a podcaster named jesse thorne in a
thread that was liked and retweeted
thousands of times by leftists who
insisted that it was heartfelt and
beautiful and of course stunning
he explains how he and his wife first
discovered that their son was a girl
and we're told that this is a perfect
explanation of the trans phenomenon
among kids perfect explanation
and i completely agree actually
so here's the story just as a good
example here
good anecdote
here's the story as he tells it
my daughter is nine when she was born we
assumed she was a boy we gave her a boy
name called her he we gave her all kinds
of toys she generally preferred the ones
our culture associates with boys like
building toys trucks and robots
she hated getting haircuts and always
wanted her hair very long like my wife's
but we just figured kids hate haircuts
she loved the jungle book especially the
part where balou the bear dresses up in
a hula skirt but what kid doesn't love
that
when she started kindergarten my wife
was bathing her an adult friend of ours
had just come out as trans and my wife
mentioned that not all girls have
vaginas and not all boys have penises
our daughter asked some girls have
penises my wife said yes
whether you were a boy or girl wasn't
about your private parts
i'm a girl with a penis my daughter said
all of a sudden all these things that
had confused us about her for so long
now made sense
so let's review the process by which
jesse and his wife came to the
conclusion
that their little boy had a little girl
mystically spiritually magically trapped
inside of him
he says that his son hated getting
haircuts
and liked a scene in a movie where a
bear wears a skirt
and that was enough
to put him on this trajectory for the
rest of his life
now even assuming that there's other
evidence of the boy's girlness which
jesse didn't mention
the fact that he mentions this
that this is presented at all
tells you everything you need to know
unless you think that this is uh that
this is a straw man and
this this is not the way it usually goes
with parents of quote unquote trans kids
no i'm here to tell you that literally
every story
from a parent
of a quote trans kid is exactly like
this
it is always oh well you know he's when
he was two years old he liked playing
with dolls
now the boy did also say that he's a
girl with a penis but he only said that
after his mother told him
that some girls had penises
if you tell a five-year-old boy that
some dragons are three and a half feet
tall and look a lot like five-year-old
boys
guess what he's almost certain to inform
you that he is just such a dragon
because kids are highly suggestible
again they can't distinguish between
fantasy and and fiction
fantasy and reality
a child at five can't be meaningfully
accused of even telling a lie because he
doesn't fully understand the difference
between a lie and a truth
when my youngest son was four i remember
um
going into the kitchen and finding a
broken glass on the floor
and i asked my four-year-old if he broke
it
and over the course of this brief
interrogation he told me that he did
break it he didn't break it it was
already broken it's not broken his
brother broke it and the dog broke it
we didn't own a dog at the time by the
way
he did not have enough of a grasp on
reality to deceive me effectively
because he's just a small child and
everything that he says every claim he
makes
should be understood in that context
now the thread goes on to describe how
the sun socially transitioned quote
unquote in in kindergarten
jesse's sun that is and now at the age
of nine
jesse is thinking about what sorts of
drugs he wants to put
the child on
he also goes into detail about the
herculean efforts needed to protect his
boy's parentally imposed delusions
it's all quite disturbing but there's
one moment of lucidity
jesse reports this
anyway she told us her new name grace
actually she initially said greece
but we figured out what she meant not
the clearest enunciator back then
huh huh
now this is indeed the duty of a parent
children say many things and often don't
know what the words that they're using
actually mean they make claims that are
not true
they express desires that are not really
their desires they announce plans that
make no sense and attempt to do things
that would get them killed or maimed
if you were not to intercede
so it's your job as a parent to use your
maturity and wisdom to guide your child
and lead them
through their own confusion
jesse heard his quote daughter
say that quote she wanted to be called
greece
jesse knows that greece is a ridiculous
name surely the boy can't actually want
that name
and even if he does it's for his own
good that you guide him to a different
name
a child at that age doesn't understand
the significance of a name
he can't look ahead into the future and
consider what it would be like to
actually live with that name for the
rest of your life
that's why we usually assign names to
our kids
but it turns out that even the parents
who let their children choose their
names still don't really let them choose
there's a reason that out of all the
trans kids quote unquote
who are allowed to choose their own
names and their own identities
have you noticed that none of them are
now legally named
dragon ninja or pirate bear or
awesome cool kid
or any of the sorts of names and
identities that a small child would
actually choose for himself
usually they end up with a simple and
traditional name for the opposite gender
or else something trendy and
gender-neutral that the parent gave them
the influence of the parents on these
choices is evident
now this is an interesting fact and it
raises a question
if they won't let a child select any
name he wants
then why would they let him select any
gender he
wants if they wouldn't let their child
be saddled by the ridiculous and
immature name choice he made as a child
why are they allowing him to be saddled
by the ridiculous and immature gender
choice he made as a toddler
it doesn't make any sense at all
but children don't know that it makes no
sense
they're not going to ask the kinds of
skeptical questions that would expose
this whole thing as a sham
and that's why the left wants to get to
them young
that's why they'll defend their grooming
and their indoctrination practices to
death
to the death as we've seen down in
florida
the future of their ideology depends on
getting to the kids and getting to them
young
before they grow a little bit and their
brains develop
and they start to notice just how
incoherent and insidious gender ideology
really is
though to be fair many adults in our
country haven't even noticed this either
they've fallen prey to the confusion
themselves which of course is all by
design
confusion in the end is is the name of
the game
it's all they have
and that's why we have to counter it
with clarity and with truth
and that's it for me thanks guys i
appreciate it
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we're going to
begin the q a portion
uh if you have a question for mr walsh
please line up next to the man in the
blue shirt back in the back wall
and we have our first question
hello matt thank you so much for coming
on to the campus um my question for you
is with so many um different leftist
ideologies to um you know focus on so
much in the news um do you have any
advice for like
sticking focus staying focused on um the
issues that that matter most
yeah i think this is one of the things
that we struggle with the most i mean i
i am always hesitant to be
uh
usually i would not be accused of
optimism but i do feel a slight i feel a
slight tinges of optimism sometimes when
i look at what's happening in the
culture right now and i think that we're
actually making headway especially when
it comes to issues like this cultural
issues
i think the lefts
when they came out explicitly against
parental rights when the democrat party
basically made parental anti-parental
rights into one of their platform things
on their platform uh that was a huge
seminal moment and but i think you're
right that um a mistake that we can make
is to get distracted by whatever shiny
object over there so i think in terms of
issues that we should be focusing on i
think
um
the issue of defending the realities of
men and women
that that to me is the central issue
that we should be focused on and we can
actually win that and the only way that
we don't win it is if we
allow ourselves to get distracted by
something else
thank you
hi matt my name is cole um so i'm going
to school to be an elementary teacher
and we have to read books like
about transgender kids and it's just
very brainwashing so i'm wondering if
you have any advice on what you would do
in that situation
well i would bring johnny the walrus
into the kindergarten classroom
[Applause]
if i have to give another answer besides
that i would i would say look i i think
first of all
to be a sane decent person going into
the public school environment into the
teaching profession that is you're doing
the lord's work literally and it takes i
think it takes a lot of heroism so i
applaud you for that
um yeah
[Applause]
i also think
i also think and this is definitely in
the it's easy for me to say category it
is easy for me to say but it's also true
that as a teacher you simply cannot
facilitate
um the sexual indoctrination of children
even if the school tells you that you
have to i think that's one of those
times when this is what we need more
teachers to do some have we need more to
say i'm just not going to do it
fire me do what you're going to do but i
refuse to go along with it so i think
this is a line in the sand type of thing
thank you
hello matt my name is talon i feel very
underdressed please forgive me for not
wearing flannel
banned me from the show if you must but
my question is do you have any intention
of discussing a convention of states on
your show it seems like there are issues
like
term limits or bills that are a
gazillion pages long that those on the
left and right who feel unrepresented by
the federal government could achieve at
the state level through a convention of
states
uh i agree with you
i have to say more i mean it's like i i
i clearly agree with you i mean this is
uh this is maybe one of my kind of blind
spots actually is that i get
i i
i zone in so
carefully on the cultural issues
that uh sometimes i can even neglect the
political issues i think you kind of
need both of that you need people that
are really focusing on the political
solutions which is what you're talking
about um and you need people focused on
on cultural issues but that's a that is
a i think one of the best political
potential political solutions
that we could
you know
that we could hope for thank you thanks
uh recent hi my name is jacob recently
the president of the united states has
made some statements on firearm policy
in this country i wanted to know what
your opinion on that was
made statements on what policy firearm
policy
fire policy firearm
weapons guns
guns okay fire fire
oh firearm policy okay
i'm like fire policy i'm against fires i
mean
um
well you have to be more specific on
what he said i don't know what
specifically he said about about gun
rights i i can tell you right now i i
disagree with it whatever it is that he
said
[Applause]
some of the things he's been talking
about is banning 80 percent kids uh one
of the new he's appointing a new
director to the atf he's also been
talking about uh changing some of the
rulings on uh stocks and pistol braces
yeah i disagree with all that all right
like i said
hello my name is alex um i was curious
about what relationship you have found
between uh excess affluence and
association with the lgbt uh especially
in the modern day period as that is sort
of a pattern throughout history
uh i do think there's a really
interesting correlation there um and we
talk i i mentioned this this
generation over generation doubling of
lgbt identification and um i now
admittedly i have not checked but i'm
someone can fact check me on this
someone could go to snopes on this one
but i'm pretty sure that we're not going
to find anything like this you know in
ethiopia or kenya or you know something
like that this this is very unique to
the western world and that's especially
the case when it comes to the trans
identification in particular um i think
that
talking about gender ideology
specifically
this is and this is actually a really
important point that we need to be
making more so i'm glad you brought it
up is that gender ideology is
a product
it is a very insular western modern
thing it's a product of our western
privilege
and if you go outside of
what modern western affluent society
um it's not just that they disagree with
it is that they don't even understand
what you're talking about
because they their their framework for
life
is completely it's
it's foreign to everything that they
believe and i actually know this for a
fact because in my film that's coming up
and i can't say a lot about it but what
is a woman's coming out
soon um i actually
did this we we tested this out and we
went to a third world country and
talked to them about some of these
issues and
you'll see what we discovered but i
think you're on to something anyway
simon i have a this is i'm sorry i have
a specific question so being that this
is a billion dollar industry that as you
yourself mentioned
there are pharmaceutical companies that
make billions off of this
would it not be in the best interest to
use the long arm of the federal
government against these companies for
instance they engage in price fixing why
not use the clean anti-trust act to
break them up also why not take away
their research grants take away their
tax breaks
make it so it is no longer
you know something they can make easy
money off of
uh i love it i'm on board for all that i
think
and it's not just with uh with what
they're doing
you know uh drugging and chemically
castrating kids i think the
pharmaceutical industry has
i here's another here's another law that
i that i would support
is um you know i would support a ban on
direct to consumer advertisements i i
don't think that there should be
advertisements where the pharmaceutical
company can put these ads out and say oh
well you know you might have this
disease and if you do here's a drug for
go talk to your doctor about that that's
not the way that's supposed to work it's
supposed to be you have symptoms and
something's going wrong in your body you
go to your doctor and talk to them about
it and and and they're supposed to help
you figure out what drug you need you
don't go to the doctor already having
the drug in mind that you want
and uh this is another thing that
outside of you know this this is this is
a new it's a relatively new modern
phenomenon
and uh so that's another law that i
think we should put in place to tamp
down on the
pharmaceutical industry yep
hey matt i'm jack uh so certainly with
your book and your film coming out we've
talked a lot about social media
entertainment all that
what are the further steps that can be
taken because clearly the left are
involved in all those
areas what are some more steps that can
be taken so that
the right can kind of find themselves a
space in that that's not cliche in a
sort of way
taken
with respect to big tech
yeah with big time i mean twitter social
media just entertainment in general that
sphere that's just been so heavily
dominated by the left in recent years
um well one thing i guess we need more
eccentric billionaires to come in and
buy some of these guys
um
unfortunately there's only there's only
one that that's any good so
um i tell you
there's there's a few things i mean it's
kind of two different issues you've got
entertainment you've got social media
when it comes to social media one of the
reasons why
i'm so happy about the elon musk news
aside from just how angry makes the left
and how hilarious it is
is that i've never been in favor of this
kind of um
this idea of like well let's as
conservatives let's go off and have our
own social media platform
and we've seen a lot of it's it's a
noble experiment i suppose it's maybe
worth a try
but then what we're doing is we're
taking our voice and we're putting it
over over on this platform that can
simply be ignored and it has no cultural
purchase whatsoever and so i think we
need to stay in the mix we need to stay
involved
and um and i would say the same in
entertainment internet i mean it's it's
i understand the temptation to just take
your ball and go home
uh to go run off into the woods
somewhere and you know live in a cabin
that's actually not maybe not a bad idea
but if you're not going to do that
then i think we have to stay involved in
the culture and figure out ways within
these systems to
sometimes even use the system against
itself that's in a small way that's
something we were able to do with johnny
the walrus and again it's a small
example but it's
you know rather than taking this book
and saying well we're not going to sell
it on amazon at all now i'd rather use
amazon i know they don't want
amazon doesn't want this book on their
platform but i want to use it against
them and against their own agenda and
their own message and so i think that's
kind of what we should be doing
thanks
[Applause]
hey matt uh greetings from minnesota sbg
for life
i just want to know i've been talking to
some of the people i graduated college
with about
money and billionaires especially you
mentioned elon musk that's come up a lot
i was just curious because i hadn't
heard a lot of it on the daily wire or
anybody else
watch your show the most but what are
your thoughts on like because i find
myself as a conservative oftentimes
arguing on the side of billionaires but
like i'm not neces i'm not necessarily
like pro billionaire but like because
some of them done kind of bad things but
economically what is your thoughts on
that like where you know obviously elon
musk is doing kind of some great things
on with the twitter side and free speech
but like how would you engage that in
some of those
conversations um
you have to be a little more specific so
like what do you mean exactly like um
economically and economic policy uh well
let me put it to you this way uh a lot
of my friends hate billionaires yeah
just straight up hate them and so like
as it's like well they you know the earn
the money that side of it what would you
say like as a conservative to what point
are we not just saying oh we love all
billionaires we want billionaires and
all that kind of thing and but where's
the uh kind of
the right okay
um
yeah i don't think uh defending
billionaires is exactly that's kind of
the argument that they want to have are
you pro or anti-billionaire
uh that's that doesn't make any sense to
me i'm not i'm not
i don't wake up every day thinking about
how much i love billionaires and i want
to defend billionaires i mean they're
billionaires they're doing a fine job of
defending themselves and it just so
happens that most of them on a personal
level i just hate because of who they
are and what they stand for jeff bezos
bill gates like i hate those guys and
it's it's not even because of
their money just makes it worse because
it gives them more power
um so it's what i would say is i'm not
pro or anti-billionaire i'm just i am in
favor of
economic freedom that's all i'm in favor
of and if you have that then you're
going to end up with some billionaires
and if you want to look at that as a
necessary evil or whatever you want to
call it i'm fine with that
categorization the other issue also is
um
you know someone is going to have
the money like if you jeff bezos got a
lot of money
and if we want to take that money from
him
well the only other option
the only other force out there that
could take it for themselves would be
the government and so do i trust the
government more than i trust jeff bezos
i don't trust either of them really but
um that's why i just fall on the side of
economic freedom you know at the end of
the day
hi matt my name is ellie and i attend a
pretty liberal community college in
duluth minnesota
and in
um the gender phenomenon and all the
pronouns and stuff that's really pushed
there so i was wondering um
how
how you would recommend
um i guess
defending against that and while you're
there
while you're at the college
the first thing the most important thing
is just on a on a personal level
to
stave off the temptation to just go
along with it
because you don't want to be
confrontational
you don't want to hurt people's feelings
uh you don't want to cause problems for
yourself i mean all of that is like it's
an understandable inclination
but part of the way that we got into
this position in our culture is that is
that that's what almost all of the sane
people have done they just like well i
don't feel like having those arguments
i'm just not gonna do it and so if you
can
stave that off and um just it doesn't
mean you have to go up and you find a
trans person start screaming at them or
screaming their biologically correct
pronouns at them no it's just i'm going
to live my life as a person i'm going to
live in the truth as a person grouted in
truth and i'm not going to compromise
that for you so that's a personal level
and then
on a kind of broader level i think and
this is something that we see
on a lot of campuses including this one
but it's also really important is to
organize
is to find because you're not you might
feel like you're the only sane person
but this is one thing that i've learned
over the last few years also is that
there was a time when i thought that i
was basically alone and then i go out
and i meet people it's no we're out
there it's just that we're not nearly as
good at organizing as the left is
and so i would say organize is the other
thing too thanks
hi matt thanks for coming today um
so the one thing that i really took from
you speaking today is the language piece
of it and how
they're manipulating the language and
how they're really like abandoning
proper language and so my question to
you is
in the education piece of all of this
why do we see the english
professors teachers being the ones that
are pushing this agenda the most
when
language is
like proper language is being abandoned
yeah well you're right um the answer is
that a lot of them are left-wing
ideologues first of all because they're
in the education system and then a lot
of the rest of them not all of them but
a lot of them are also cowards and they
know that this is wrong but it's just
again it's the same story we talked
about before
um
and one of the ways by the way that we
ended up with a lot of ideal left-wing
ideologues in the public school system
teaching english and every other subject
is that well they're filtering out of
college and so this is this is one thing
that for so long and i was guilty of
this too
conservatives we would look at all the
purple haired you know lefties on
college campuses and we would kind of
laugh and we would say oh they're gonna
they're gonna go out into the real world
and they're gonna have a wake-up call
and uh
they got something really in store for
them
and it turns out that no we we were the
ones who needed the wake-up call
because they went out into the real
world and
became public school teachers you know
they they changed the world to suit
their needs they didn't change for the
world like we all thought they would
and so there's this kind of like
self-perpetuating cycle in this in the
uh in the education system which is how
you end up with that i think
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen this is going to be
the last question of the evening
so make it good pressure's on
i just wanted to say i don't actually
have a question but somebody brought a
brought up the convention of states and
i brought a gift for you it's a book
called consent of the governed and it's
a different solution other than the
convention estate so i just wanted to
pass that on to this gentleman who can
get it to you
i will i will end on a gift i kind of
like that i appreciate it
[Applause]